and people tell you no you say actually
yes welcome back to grammar with me
justin hays and today we're joined by
the woman who's shutting down London
Fashion Week Queen Victoria Beckham oh I
like that thank you for interviewing me
um Wayne always a treat to see you
it's been so great to feel part of
London Fashion Week this is the first
time that I've that I've shown here and
so I'm very I'm excited I'm emotional
I'm very tired I'm a little bit
delirious but I'm super happy what have
you learned about being girl boss in a
decade and design do you think you know
I've learned an enormous amount you know
I've had to learn on the job if you like
I've surrounded myself with the right
people I've been very honest I've been
focused you know the collections are
always very honest to me ultimately it's
about my customer it's about women
it's celebrating women you've always
been such an incredible role model for
girls out there what would you want to
say to all the young girls and boys out
there what kind of advice would you want
to impart in them you know I think to
embrace who you are
I've always said it since I was really
young with the Spice Girls it's okay to
be different and when people tell you no
you say actually yes and you keep going
and you believe in yourself you can
never dream too big you know I was never
the popular girl at school you know I
never found anything easy and I was told
no constantly if I can do it then anyone
can do it you've got to work hard and
I'm still so excited I love what I do
what would you say to yourself of 10
years ago what do you say to them you
know I would just say enjoy the journey
and that's I have enjoyed the journey
I really do I wake up every day and I
pinch myself I really have enjoyed the
last 10 years I've learned an enormous
amount and to just to just enjoy it and
work hard and I've done that anyway what
do you hope the legacy of Victoria
Beckham around oh my goodness what do I
have a question you know I want to give
my customer what she wants I want to be
known
somebody that really does embrace the
woman and make her feel good make her
feel powerful make her feel like the
best version of herself make her feel
special make her feel feminine make her
feel sexy in an intelligent way and what
would you say the clove in Commandments
you have learned in 10 years in fashion
I would just say you know dress in a way
that you feel comfortable and in a way
that suits you be honest with yourself
but also have fun with fashion you know
I mean look at some of the looks and
I've that I've sort of shown over here
and that's okay you know you can have
fun with fashion as well it's a journey
and don't be afraid to express yourself
express your personality that's what's
been so great about you know this
t-shirt campaign which which I love that
I shot with Juergen teller you know I
think it shows personality the sense of
humor and I take what I do very very
seriously
but you can still have fun as well
you've got to take yourself too
seriously
so get your t-shirts on and please do
send me the pictures I've got to say
people have been tagging me in their
t-shirt which I see everything and it
offends me however I have been howling
it has kept me entertained this week
have the kids tried them out they got
them all like a squad picture of their
newsroom no but that's a good idea
dude you should do that now yeah no I
see you hold tight for the next 10 years
[Music]